this video is being released on
Christmas Day we haven't made the
Christmas video for a long time so we're
going to make up for it by lots of
Christmas videos what I want to show you
as some of the presents that I've been
sent by you YouTube viewers and I've
collected on my travels around the UK
around the world and they've all got
something really quite interesting and
chemical about them and some of them
have got really nice stories so let's
begin with this one this looks like a
sort of biscuit that you might get in a
cafe health food it's actually solid and
quite heavy it was given to me in one
piece but it broke in my luggage and it
is the deposit that is formed inside an
enormous wine barrel I visited a
vineyard where they make wine which
belongs to the president of the Swiss
Academy of Sciences so he can really
entertain in style and we sat among
these huge barrels big enough for
somebody to get inside on each table
there were lumps of this material so I
must say in this case I had to ask for
some rather than being given it as a
complete gift by told him that I thought
it'd make an interesting youtube video
now I haven't tested this myself he told
me that it was tartaric acid though it
might be a tartrate tartaric acid is an
interesting molecule because it was one
of the first that was discovered to
demonstrate left-handed and right-handed
forms but I don't know whether the
people who discovered it discovered it
in wine or somewhere else but I was
amazed that you should have things like
this inside the wine barrel and if you
look it's really quite thick so it's not
just some tiny deposit
is this like a this is a bad thing this
is ruins the wine or this is like a
sucker is this like a waste product or I
think that tartaric acid is a waste
product but a small amount of it stays
in the wine and gives part of the flavor
the flavors of wine are made up from a
whole series of different compounds so
you need just a pinch of this a bit of
that and so on so if there was no
tartaric acid at all it wouldn't taste
the same was your host surprised when
you asked to keep it I'm not sure I'll
have to ask him when I see him next he's
a space scientist astrophysicists so I
think deposits in wine barrels are not
his area of science so this is my
present for the first day of Christmas
and there are lots more to come for all
12 days of Christmas and some days have
more than one present
I think it's absolutely
Oh
you